today the fda announcing it is expected
to authorize the use of pfizer's covid
vaccine for
12 to 15 year olds very soon the
approval is highly anticipated after the
drug maker said the vaccine
was found to be safe and effective and
produce robust antibody responses
in those 12 to 15 year olds in a
clinical trial kirsten joins live in
studio joining us with details
on how health care providers are
planning for what could be an influx
brian the vaccine has already been
cleared in the u.s for those age 16 and
above
and dr anthony fauci said he believes
it's going to be authorized within
several days for this younger group
this approval would boost the
immunization drive across the u.s
help with some parents concerns about
the potential impact of covet 19 on
their kids as they get ready to attend
say summer camp and
return to school full-time in the fall
during today's covet call the team
discussed the strategy for getting
younger teens vaccinated as soon as they
are eligible
we have been engaging and plan to engage
more pediatricians
um who are the prime you know medical
care provider
for um up into the later adolescent
years
and that's really a key component is
again the most trusted source for
vaccine information
survey across survey is a person's
health care provider or a health care
provider in their community
and so that's really where we want to
lead parents
they say many pediatricians are excited
and ready to vaccinate their patient
population
the cova task force also working on
adding information for parents to its
envy coveted fighter site that'll be
available in the next week once they see
authorization come through
as far as administering the vaccine at
large as we've reported the coveted task
force does believe nevadans have been
very receptive to it
citing the 46 percent initiated is above
most flu season vaccination percentages
and while there has been a drop since
the beginning they expect to see the
daily doses administered plateau
but say doses administered every day is
a win in our state